In this section we are going to look at a
different type of spatial image processing
operation. To illustrate this I am going to
take the Mona Lisa image and I have chosen
a large number of random pixels within the
image and I have set them to either 0 or 1.
This is sometimes called speckle noise or
salt and pepper noise. The image now is corrupted;
it has got a large number of white and black
spots on it.
One way to try and reduce the effect of this
noise would be to compute an average. We have
seen before how the averaging operation tends
to blur out and reduce fine detail, so if
I compute the average of this noise-corrupted
image we can see that the intensity of these
noise pixels has got less, but they have also
tended to get a little bit bigger. They have
been smeared out, they are now wider, but
they are not as distinct from the background.
If I increase the size of the kernel that
we use for averaging we can see that the salt
and pepper noise has perhaps almost completely
disappeared, but there has been some collateral
damage, the image now is quite blurry. So
is there a way that we can reduce this salt
and pepper noise without removing the fine
detail in the image that we want?
And indeed there is the technique called rank
filtering, so to look at how this works we
are going to zoom in on a very small 3 by
3 patch of the original image and we see some
grey level values here and they are typically
around the 120 to a 130—the grey level values
that should be at this particular region—and
we see that pixel has got a value of 0 … this
is a noise pixel.
If we compute the average over this window,
we see that it has a value of a 110. Now this
value is a bit lower than the other values
that are around here; we probably wouldn’t
be expecting a value of a 110 here.
And what has happened is that this value of
0 is so far away from the values that should
be here that it has pulled the average down,
it’s influenced the average.
We want a different sort of statistic, and
a statistic like the median value is actually
more helpful. So the median value across this
3 by 3 median would be a 123 and that would
perhaps be a much better guess at what the
value should be at this location. How do we
compute the median? Well the simplest way
to compute the median is to take all of the
values within this 3 by 3 window and stack
them up from the largest through to the smallest.
We are going to rank them and rank number
1 pixel is the maximum value within this window.
Rank 9, is the minimum value with in this
window. And rank 5 is the median value and
it is the median value we are interested in.
So let’s apply a median filter to the Mona
Lisa image. There she is with the salt and
pepper noise and here she is after we have
applied a 3 by 3 median filter—we can see
that the effect of the noise has been dramatically
reduced, but the fine detail in the image
has been mostly retained.
To compute this we use the tool box function
irank. First argument is the input image.
This case it would be noise corrupted Mona
Lisa, the second argument is a 3 by 3 matrix
of ones, which indicates the size of the region
over which we want to compute the median.
And the last argument 5 is the rank that we
want to choose. Because we have asked for
median over a 3 by 3 window, rank 5 is the
middle value of the nine elements within that
window.